so how does a screenwriter set up a
meeting with an executive is it just you
just oh let's go on IMDB Pro okay this
is this person's contact alright let me
find now okay so much there are
different ways that you can do it
obviously having representation is the
easiest way to do this if we go back to
friends of friends if you know somebody
who knows somebody who can get your
script to somebody I would not try and
set up a meeting I would try and get my
script read and then set up a meeting
because if somebody responds to your
material they'll probably call you but
if not get them your material and then
waited wait awhile give them six weeks
two months to read it just check-in in
six weeks and say I know how incredibly
busy you are just wondering if you've
had a chance to read it don't be
annoying sometimes it takes six months
or eight months and then once they read
it then you could say I would love to
meet with you if you have the time you
can try cold nobody's gonna do that I
mean in a smaller production company if
you can if you're following them on
Twitter or maybe Facebook you know
you're a friend of theirs on Facebook
you could do a private message and say
I'm an aspiring writer would you ever
have 15 minutes to meet with me and give
me career advice there's a lot of people
that'll do that okay and let's suppose
this person says yes then you say hey
can I take you out to coffee and you
meet them where they live or how do you
do that you go to their office you at
you invite them for coffee
never lunch never dinner these people
have lives they don't know you so they
are not going to give up one of their
lunches to meet with you invite them for
coffee or go to their office I meet with
a number of young people because I know
a lot of professors because of my book
and I say to all of the professors that
I
meet with or do workshops with if you
have somebody who's fantastic really
exceptional let me know about it and
I'll meet with them so I will meet with
newcomers if if they've been referred to
me by somebody that I know did that
answer your question if it did and then
so then you meet with them and you send
a follow-up thank you absolutely
depending on their age so let's suppose
they're over 25 email money matter I
think so okay
within 24 hours 24 hours okay and do you
talk about more issues in terms of your
script or you keep it very brief in
terms of the email that you're sending
yeah are you you just thank them from
meeting with you you mentioned one thing
that happened in the meeting that you
found helpful that they said or an
interesting you know we're so
interesting when we discussed X and then
you might say if you have the time or
there's someone in your office that
would read my script I'd be very
grateful if not I totally understand
that's if they haven't read it if
somehow they've met with you and they
haven't read it you can ask them in in
one sentence I know how busy you are is
there anyone in your office that would
be willing to read it and give me notes
because the truth is they'll give it to
their assistant or a reader and if it
comes through with positive coverage
then that person will read it themselves
and and it's understood that you're
giving it to them it's going in to their
company in some way and if it's good
then it will be refer it will be
recommended to the person that you met
with okay so you send that email let's
suppose you hear nothing from that email
do you follow up you do you give it
you mean the email where you said would
you read my script yeah it's kind of a
dual like thank you and I appreciate by
the way yes would you or if you as you
know I'm as we discussed I'm looking for
a
a job if you hear something please
consider me I'm attaching my resume
right you could do something like that I
would give it three to four weeks and I
would check back in okay and then I
would well on something like that I
would give it three weeks and I would
stay in touch with people every four
months or so to stay on their radar if
you've asked them may I stay in touch
with you and what you want to do is stay
in touch with people when you don't need
anything from them when you're emailing
them to congratulate them on something
good news either for them or for you
don't meet somebody and just take
introduce me to so-and-so read my script
get my script to somebody you know form
a genuine relationship before you ask
for something
you